let me ask you about uh
something that you know i think about a
little bit in this modern world which is
monogamy
so i personally value monogamy one girl
ride or die there you go right no that's
exactly it
but that said
i i don't know what's the right way to
approach this
but from an evolutionary biology
perspective or from just looking at
modern society that seems to be an idea
that's not
what's the right way to put it
flourishing
it is waning it's waning um
so i i suppose based on your reaction
you're also a supporter of monogamy or
the
you value monogamy are you and i just
um delusional
um what can you say about monogamy
from the context of your book from the
context of evolutionary biology
from the context of being human yeah i
can say
that i fully believe that we are
actually enlightened and that although
monogamy is waning that it is not waning
because there is a superior system
it is waning for predictable other
reasons
so let us just say it is
there is a lot of pre-trans fallacy here
where people go through a phase where
they recognize
that actually we know a lot about the
evolution
of monogamy and we can tell from the
fact that humans are
somewhat sexually dimorphic that there
has been
a lot of polygony in human history and
in fact
most of human history was largely
poligenous
but it is also the case that most of the
people on earth today belong to
civilizations that are at least
nominally monogamous
and have practiced monogamy and that's
not
anti-evolutionary what that is is part
of
what i mentioned before where human
beings can swap out their software
program
and different mating patterns are
favored in different periods of history
so i would argue
that the benefit of monogamy the primary
one that drives the evolution of
monogamous patterns in humans
is that it brings all adults into child
rearing
now the reason that that matters is
because human babies are
very labor intensive in order to raise
them properly having two parents
is a huge asset and having more than two
parents having an extended family
also very important but
what that means is that for a population
that is expanding
a monogamous mating system makes sense
it makes sense because it means that the
number of offspring that can be raised
is elevated it's elevated because all
potential parents are involved in
parenting whereas if you sideline a
bunch of males by having a polygenous
system in which one male has many
females which is typically the way that
works
what you do is you sideline all those
males which means the total amount of
parental effort is lower
and the population can't grow so what
what i'm arguing is that
you should expect to see populations
that face
the possibility of expansion endorsed
monogamy
and at the point that they have reached
carrying capacity you should expect to
see polygamy break back out
and what we are seeing is a kind of
false sophistication
around polyamory which will end up
breaking down
into polygeny which will not be in the
interest of most people
really the only people whose interests
it could be argued to be
in would be the very small number of
males at the top
who have many partners and everybody
else suffers
is it possible to make the argument if
we focus in on those males
at the quote unquote top with uh many
female partners
is it possible to say that that's a
sub-optimal life
that a single partner is the optimal
life well it depends what you mean i
have a feeling that you and i wouldn't
have to go very far
to figure out that um
what might be evolutionarily optimal
doesn't match
my values as a person then i'm sure it
doesn't match yours either you know
try to can we try to dig into the that
gap between those two
sure um i mean we can do it very simply
uh selection
might favor your engaging in war
against a defenseless enemy or genocide
right it's not hard to figure out how
that might put your genes at advantage
i don't know about you lex i'm not
getting involved in no genocide
it's not going to happen i won't do it i
will do anything to avoid it so
some part of me has decided that my
conscious self
and the values that i hold trump my
evolutionary self
and once you figure out that in some
extreme case that's true
and then you realize that that means it
must be possible in many other cases and
you start going through all of the
things that selection would favor and
you realize that a fair fraction of the
time
actually you're not up for this you
don't want to be
some robot on a mission that involves
genocide when necessary
you want to be your own person and
accomplish things that you think are
valuable and so among those
are not advocating you know let's
suppose you're in a position to be one
of those males at the top of a
politicianist system
we both know why that would be rewarding
right
but we also both recognize really yeah
sure
lots of sex yeah okay what else lots of
sex and lots of variety
right so look every red-blooded american
russian male can understand why that's
appealing
right on the other hand it is up against
an alternative
which is having a partner with whom
one is bonded especially closely
right right and so a love
right well you know i don't wanna i
don't wanna
uh straw man the polygamy position
obviously polygamy is complex and
there's nothing that stops
a man presumably from loving multiple
partners and from them loving him
back but in term you know if love is
your thing there's a question about
okay what is the quality of love if it
is divided over multiple partners
right and what is the net consequence
for love
in a society when multiple people will
be frozen out for every individual
male in this case who has it and
what i would argue is and you know
this is weird to even talk about but
this is partially me just talking from
personal experience
i think there actually is a monogamy
program in us and it's not automatic
but if you take it seriously
you can find it and frankly
marriage and it doesn't have to be
marriage but whatever it is that results
in the lifelong bond with a partner
has gotten a very bad rap you know it's
the butt of too many jokes
but the truth is it's hugely rewarding
it's not easy but if you know that
you're looking for something right if
you know that the objective actually
exists and it's not some utopian fantasy
that can't be found
if you know that there's some real world
you know
warts and all version of it then you
might actually think hey that is
something i want and you might pursue it
and my guess is you'd be very happy when
you find it
yeah i think there is uh getting to the
fundamentals of the emergency i feel
like there is some kind of physics of
love so one
there is a conservation thing going on
so if you have like many partners
yeah in theory you should be able to
love all of them deeply but it seems
like in reality that love gets split
yep now there's another law that's
interesting in terms of monogamy
i don't know if it's the physics level
but if you
are in a monogamous relationship by
choice
and almost as um in slight rebellion
to social norms that's much more
powerful like if you choose
that one partnership that's also more
powerful
if you if like everybody's in the
monogamy there's this pressure to be
married in this pressure society
that's different because that's almost
like a constraint on your freedom
that is enforced by something other than
your own ideals it's
by by somebody else when you yourself
choose to i guess create these
constraints
that enriches that love so there's some
kind of love function
like e equals mc squared but for love
that i feel like
if you have less partners and it's done
by choice
that can maximize that and that love can
transcend
the biology transcend the evolutionary
biology forces
that have to do much more with survival
and all those kinds of things
it can transcend to take us to to a
richer experience
which we have the luxury of having
exploring of happiness
of of joy of fulfillment all those kinds
of things
totally agree with us and there's no
question
that by choice when there are other
choices
imbues it with meaning that it might not
otherwise
have i would also say you know i'm
i'm really struck by and i have a hard
time not feeling
terrible sadness over what
younger people are coming to think about
this topic
i think they're missing something so
important and so hard to phrase
that and they don't even know that
they're missing it they might know that
they're unhappy
but they don't understand what it is
they're even looking for because
nobody's really been honest with them
about what their choices are and i have
to say
if i was a young person or if i was
advising a young person which i used to
do
again a million years ago when i was a
college professor four years ago
but i used to you know talk to students
i knew my students really well and they
would ask questions about this and they
were always curious because heather and
i seemed to have a good relationship and
many of them knew both of us
so they would talk to us about this if i
was
advising somebody i would say do not
bypass the possibility that what you are
supposed to do
is find somebody worthy
somebody who can handle it somebody who
you are compatible with and that you
don't have to be perfectly compatible
it's not about dating until you find the
one it's about finding somebody
whose underlying values and viewpoint
are complementary to yours sufficient
that you fall in love
if you find that person opt out together
get out of this damn system that's
telling you what's sophisticated to
think about
love and romance and sex ignore it
together
right that's the key and i believe
you'll end up laughing in the end if you
do it you'll discover
wow that's a hellscape that i opted out
of
and this thing i opted into complicated
difficult worth it nothing that's worth
it
is ever not difficult so we should we
should even just skip the whole
statement about difficult yeah all right
i just i want to be honest it's not like
oh it's
you know it's non-stop joy no it's
freaking complex
but um but worth it no question in my
mind
you